l'europe durement touchée par la seconde
vague de covile 19 ce dimanche l'espagne
a pris de nouvelles mesures pour
endiguer la crise l'état d'urgence
sanitaire y est prolongé jusqu'au début
du mois de mai tout le pays est soumis à
un couvre feu nocturne de 23 heures à 6
heures du matin à l'exception des îles
canaries
le premier ministre espagnol pedro
sanchez a détaillé des règles sanitaires
qui sont entrées en vigueur
quand barack obama je suis ici pour vous
informer que le gouvernement réunis en
cabine extraordinaire vient de déclarer
l'état d'urgence dans tout le pays qui
entrera en vigueur cet après midi et
samedi matin la liberté de circulation
des personnes est interdite de 23 heures
à 6 heures du matin dans tout le pays
il ne sera possible de circuler dans ce
fuseau horaire que pour les raisons
justifiées établi dans le règlement par
exemple pour acquérir des médicaments
pour remplir des obligations
professionnelles ou de travail pour
rentrer chez soi ou pour s'occuper
d'adultes ou de mineurs
en italie le président du conseil
antonio conte et a également annoncé de
nouvelles mesures restrictives fermeture
des théâtres et des cinémas et
obligations pour les bars et les
restaurants de baisser de rideau dès 18
heures badger la télé parce que c'est
chez les russes 30 et les bar glacier
boulangeries restaurants fermeront à 18h
tous les jours même les jours fériés les
week-ends après 18 heures ils seront
autorisés à livrer ou à faire à manger
emporté les restaurants ne pourront
accepter que des tables de quatre
personnes
sauf s'il s'agit d'une famille plus
nombreuse il est interdit de consommer
de la nourriture ou des boissons sur les
places ou dans les rues publiques après
18 heures les célébrations ne sont plus
autorisés jusqu'à présent elle avait une
limite de 30 personnes
les conférences conventions et autres
événements seront uniquement autorisés à
distance
toutes les foires même internationales
sont suspendus une annonce qui
intervient après des échauffourées à
rome dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
des militants nationalistes sont
rassemblés pour manifester contre le
couvre-feu instauré dans la région de la
capitale après des heurts avec les
forces de l'ordre
plusieurs personnes ont été interpellées
et des policiers ont été blessés à
berlin une manifestation pacifique était
organisée ce dimanche contre les
restrictions du gouvernement parmi les
motifs de mécontentement le quasi
confinement imposé dans un canton située
en bavière ou encore le port du masque
obligatoire dans certains quartiers de
la capitale
le maire de berlin and sand exclure
aucune option
je dois avouer qu un recond finement
n'est plus exclu nous n'avons plus
beaucoup de marges et d'options des
règles du même type également contesté
au royaume uni dans le centre de londres
ce dimanche des manifestants ont
protesté contre la fermeture des bars
dans certaines régions parfois sans
masque ils se sont heurtés aux forces de
l'ordre déployés pour les contenir
de son côté si la bulgarie n'échappe pas
non plus à la seconde vague épidémique
son premier ministre a été testé positif
aux copies de 19 alors que le nombre de
contaminations flambent dans le pays
face à la recrudescence des cas l'europe
se prépare à une fin d'année très
délicate